let me ask you something else here I
want to ask you about your your family
yeah because you mentioned families
there a lot of stuff has been written
about you and your family a lot of it
fueled by you by Kim by others where are
things now with your family what is what
is your relationship like with Kim with
your kids
uh
uh
Kim has
zionists media handlers
surrounding her all in and out her Hulu
TV show all in and out her her family
all in or out the house that I created
for my family but God is alive the Devil
is a defeated Foe and Kim is a Christian
woman and she's not here just to have
content up on adult channels she's not
here just to have that last interview
magazine uh cover if you look at the two
interview magazine covers look at the
one when I was there and look at the one
when I'm not there and that's the reason
why this Tuskegee experiment of such
that's happened to the black community
where they took the fathers out of the
home and the leaders out of the
community and have torn apart the
community now they've seen that's worked
and they're doing that to America
they're attempting they're trying I mean
the interview the interview magazine
cover you're talking about I think is
the one where she was basically
semi-naked in front of the American flag
and I thought that was pretty
distasteful actually
it was about the American dream and I
thought well if that's the American
dream we're all screwed I mean in
America
and I and I agree with that and I I
didn't feel the platform to voice my
opinion because I wanna it's always like
hey this is your kid's mother this year
but it's time with the leaders like I'm
still the priest of that home Chris I'm
still the priest of that home
they they want to make it this matriarch
Society all that and you know but I am
the priest of this home and God is alive
I am the living Robert Kardashian and
I'm going to stand up for what God would
want as a Christian and then people say
as a Christian or you're not supposed to
curse you're not supposed to have
righteous indignation but I do you know
Christians had swords also Christian's
got guns I tell you that you know so but
do you talk to him I mean there have
been reports here that you and Kim don't
really talk at the moment she's
distancing herself from me because of
the stuff you've been saying was getting
controversy is that true
I mean John Legend is distant distancing
my himself from me and buying more
Christmas sweaters in the middle of
spring also so I'm not saying that you
know they're making the right decisions
uh she's being influenced you know but I
guarantee you what's not gonna happen
we're not going to seeing one of them
John Legend Christmas sweaters no time
soon but do you talk to her are you
still in touch wait said don't you think
it's like don't you think it's like
funny to like make a joke out of stuff
sometimes don't you think like God has a
sense of humor oh God but watch this God
God when I got married I bought this
house I like you know what I'm saying I
did this tour and spent all the money I
had on this house to like surprise Kim
and give her this house that she wanted
that Lisa Marie Presley used to own and
um and then I got the house and then I
put all this money into renovation and
then there goes the neighborhood Drake
moves down the street five blocks and
that's when I knew God was funny but
watch this is where God is even funnier
here goes like Louis CK part two level
because Louis CK is the funniest man
alive uncancel him now right so the and
he was funnier before he's canceled
because all he would do is type of jokes
that you'd get canceled all right so uh
uh so
um I got an office
and you know outside of Crenshaw like in
an opportunity Zone and this office 57
000 square foot office is the one that
Tucker Carlson came to visit me at and I
look out the window and who's all and
whose office is being built a brand new
one the skims office
is like who's writing this stuff you
know I'm saying like God is funny so
that's the thing we always got to be
like we got to be funny we got to have a
sense of humor like you know but yeah
let me ask you let me ask you there's a
lot but are you are you sad that you're
getting divorced are you sad the
relationship came to an end
that happened to you we got to do
divorce two year yeah yeah
we've been got divorce yeah I mean let
me rephrase that are you sad that that
you're no longer together that you're
divorced
we'll always be together
she dresses exactly like me what do you
mean like my kids are me you know
there's no person that she'll ever get
with that will influence her more than
God and then her priest on Earth which
was me you know whether it's the the
skims clothing line the designers the
The Architects all those people you got
the clintons the left
utilizing what we built together to try
to use her as an influence for the black
culture and the word culture in general
for the next elections they need those
300 million followers from Kylie and Kim
on their side going into their election
as they push trauma culture to the black
people again as they claim anything any
my questions of business dealings to be
anti-semitic comments and push you know
Kim to you know as a billionaire mother
of a lawyer and a mother of four Jew
black children
uh
uh to do covers like interview and
that's what happens when they take the
dads out the home and that's what
they've been doing in the hood they take
the fathers and the leaders out of the
homes and if we keep on allowing this to
happen and we don't have some level of a
decency Clause inside of our media on
what everyone sees like when I was young
and I would go to the video store if I
wanted to go into the adult section it
was a curtain it was a person sitting
there watching making sure that kids
didn't go in if the kids went into that
section there was a video camera and
they would have you be escorted out of
that section now that section is forced
through Tick Tock that section is
subverted and kind of mixed with the
drink inside of Music directed at
children inside of content through
Disney on Hulu which is Disney also and
in so many branded commercials to
confuse children and to sexualize our
children way too early yeah they can
even make their own decisions about
their life look you make some very
interesting points again just to clarify
one thing though you are actually
divorced are you because my
understanding was that you weren't
actually divorced yet
you know I asked God the same question
some mornings
am I divorced God am I am I divorced
because I might be divorced on paper but
I'm not divorced of the idea of being
the protector of not only this person
who is so influential imagine Kim
making all of her decisions that she
does publicly you know grown folks
businesses grown folks business never
know what could happen with a little
sippy sippy or whatever but you know all
the decisions that she makes publicly
being based on an audience of one and
Pierce what audience do you think I'm
saying that is well you
no not me for us as Christians right uh
who is our audience we have an audience
of one well you mean God
God so Picture This World Envision this
world here's another one this is past my
whole this is past what I'm saying about
having the con the the heads of the
football teams and the basketball teams
and the music industry uh opening up
their contracts the way I do right
picture the most influential woman on
the planet which is Kim Kardashian right
um
and I got this one thing I want to
definitely say in the interview
um
picture the most influential person
on the planet the most influential woman
on the planet
performing in public only for that
audience of one for God imagine the
overwhelmingly positive effect that that
will have on the planet and
Mark these words it will happen someday
okay I had this thing I had this like
you know of course I'm I'm a divorced
and this is like a a funny thing I
thought being that her name is no longer
West
and my name is no longer yay if there
was ever I mean sorry being that her
name is no longer West and my name is
now only yea if we were ever to be
together again what would our name be
kimye
would you like that
everything is up to God and God
has proven to me
many times that it's not about what I
want or what I would like
it's just up
to him
on what he sees
fit but you know David let me ask you I
mean yeah do you still love the Sheep
sorry not with an S do you still love
Kim
I absolutely love I'll love her for life
and I'll pray and I will protect oddly
enough I'll actually protect her because
when I call out things that I feel are
wrong you know what I'm saying when I
make products like say the difference
between me and Bernard or no
like say watch Elon Musk every product
the reason why Elon Musk is like a Steve
Jobs is
if he makes a flamethrower he would use
that flamethrower if he makes a cyber
truck he would use that cyber truck me
if I make some 3D printed boots you know
I'm gonna have the the 3D printed boots
on Wow every day can I get a pair
absolutely sir
These Boots Are a hit love bugs yes
those are fantastic
would you like to one day sir do you
think given that you've got all these
kids together
would you like one day to get back with
Kim do you think do you feel like you've
gone through a very tumultuous period
but that actually the love Underneath It
All between two people remains and would
you like to get back together
those thirst traps still be fire
is that do you understand what I said do
you understand that language
you better explain it explain it to me
what do you think those thirst traps
still be fire means can you explain that
to me well with my uh rather rather
straps still be fire I would imagine it
means these brilliant British man I
would imagine it means you still fancy
or what your ex-wife is that right
you know I I would prefer to not be put
on this uh I would never I would prefer
to not be put
on the spot
uh on these kind of questions what I can
say is
uh God is a God is alive and
he places people he placed David in
uh
uh to tend to to God had David tend to
the Sheep knowing that one day he would
prepare him to fight Goliath